Supreme Court justice Brett Kavanaugh of
course back in the news after the New
York Times published a story about
another claim of sexual misconduct that
took place while he was attending Yale
well now the New York Times is getting
backlash not because the allegation but
because of this tweet that the New York
Times sent out to promote the story this
is real check it out having a penis
thrust in your face at a drunken dorm
party may seem like harmless fun but
when Brett Kavanaugh did it to her
Deborah Ramirez says it confirmed that
she didn't belong at Yale in the first
place that was from the New York Times
it's real and yeah they actually refer
to having that kind of sexual assault
harmless fun the tweet also well it
seems just very sexist and kind of
blames the victim a lot of people very
upset
The Times quickly deleted the tweet and
apologized calling it poorly phrased I
wanted to find out how this tweet got
posted at all so here to speak to me now
via satellite is New York Times social
media editor mark Weller
mark thank you very much
for for joining us
yeah I I'm happy to have a chance to
apologize yet again for the poorly
phrased tweet that we have already
deleted thank you and good night
no no wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wheat but how could you not
realize how offensive it was in the
first place the social media news cycle
is extremely fast and often we have to
make decisions on the fly so mistakes
can happen and anyway we quickly deleted
that tweet and replaced it with this one
okay everyone loves a penis in their
face but for some reason Debra Ramirez
doesn't I guess she's not Yale material
see problem solved no no no that one's
even worse that's exactly what I said so
we took that one down and our entire
editorial team put their heads together
and came up with this one yeah well good
knock knock who's there
penis in your face penis in your face
who penis in your face it girl
you just not yell mature you cannot you
can't be serious about that agreed
agreed which is why it's just been
deleted we were just trying to clear the
path for this one penis is known for
their beauty especially up close the
closer your eyeball the better but this
weirdo didn't it no no no taking care of
it we here's our winner okay flappity
flap goes the dingdong equals lows for
all but not for this debbie downer
already deleted all right replaced with
this one okay a judge's and eight
eggplant emojis
sorry I meant this one this one alright
for God's sakes you're terrible you are
terrible at your job sir terrible sir
I'm sorry I don't appreciate how you're
telling me how to do my job I don't come
to where you work and slap the dicks out
of it oh that's an idea
[Applause]